were you supposed to star in the movie
Gravity with Angelina Jolie of course it
ended up being George Clooney and Sandra
Bullock right and the movie made a ton
of dough and it was very successful he
did great you were supposed you were the
first choice
and you in fact well go ahead everybody
winds up doing what they're supposed to
do right and sometimes uh someone gets
in a motorcycle accident and then the
person winds up doing the part kills it
and you say I couldn't have imagined
anyone else there I came on early in the
development process I don't think
Angelini was even attached at that point
right but uh Alfonso and I really kind
of hit it off and then by the time I
said you know Sandy Bullock is really
and I've heard stories like this from
Clooney himself where you kind of you're
involved in things and you just kind of
want to help whether you wind up being
in it or not because you like the people
involved and it was that kind of story
yeah but you were in it and then you
said you got out of it by telling the
director I can't work in this confined
space I don't want to be just locked in
a [ __ ] Tin Can for a whole movie what
I can tell you is I went to do a test
with a new sort of
multi-spherical camera thing they were
doing for how they were going to do all
the CGI and
um and I'm one of those guys who can be
comfortably uncomfortable pretty easily
right and I went in the morning to do
that and we did it for about 20 minutes
I said this is crazy how much longer
they go it's like another two to four
hours I said no it isn't it and you left
you gotta have boundaries you got to
leave before you flip out right you
think if you would know like Clooney got
a 70 million dollar paycheck off of that
movie and so did Sandra Bullock 70 mil
okay maybe you would have put up with
that [ __ ] harness if you'd known that
you know at the time it didn't it wasn't
clear if this thing would be huge again
you can any of us can have anything but
we can't have everything
foreign